so you're mainly known for the voice of  Bugs Bunny at  [Music]  characters brought to you by yeah  [Music]  my childhood if you have a pen and paper  I can actually I haven't actually drawn  in a while I started with the nose in  the mouth and we're gonna go with the  you got to use his voice as your drama  well doc you got to make sure you got  that cute little tiny nose and um the  three Tufts of hair and the the back of  the skull the other side of the cheek  he's got six whiskers doc wow and then I  always I never leave room for my big  floppy ears right here I don't wanna I  don't want to draw on your on your fancy  marble table you could do anything you  want that's pretty much bugs dunk wow  ain't he a stinking so yeah I mean holy  [ __ ]  that's buggy it's a rough uh  assimilation of that looks like the one  on the cartoons though this is this is  this is pretty much it